[Music]
he's the host of the school of greatness
podcast since 2013 over 40 million
downloads there and nearly a million
views in the first 24 hours of the first
episode on Facebook watch inspiring life
with Lois house every available episode
comes Monday right at noon Eastern Time
first episode aired just a couple of
Monday's ago good to see you Lois has
read me how are you
they're doing incredible you know when
you get to wake up and you feel healthy
being out in LA it always feels good so
do you live out here now or I live in
West Hollywood okay and every day for me
I do a lot of trips around the world and
see a lot of different people and
experiences and I'm sure you get to see
a lot of different people and
experiences as well right and every time
I see someone with nothing who's happy
and I'm living in you know LA where a
lot of people want to visit or want to
live and I'm healthy and I've got things
happening my life I feel very grateful
so I guess what is the message that you
try to deliver every day it all depends
but the key is to live in gratitude mmm
chase the thing you love could be your
dreams or just the thing you love and
then be in service you know you talked
about being serviceable but this is
being in service to other people right
sure and I think if we can follow those
three things and it's a pretty good life
you know we don't have to struggle as
much if we can focus on three things
which is focus on your health being
grateful for it pursue the thing you
love and then give back some give back
to your friends your family your
community and as your reach and
influence grows give back to the world
it's it sounds so simple very simple but
it is not easy to accomplish not easy no
so what what have you overcome Lois for
those who might know how deep we call it
here let's go deep we talk all about a
lot of deep stuff I mean when I was five
I was raped by a man that I didn't know
and for 25 years I used sports as my
outlet to get the aggression out it was
my safe environment to express emotion
because growing up in the Midwest there
wasn't like a safe environment with your
peers or your teammates to talk about
the challenges that you had I think my
parents at the time didn't have the
emotional capacity to really know how to
even talk about
with their kids of and they didn't know
even it happened because I was ashamed
and guilty of it so at five that
happened then my brother went to prison
when I was eight so for four and a half
years when he was in jail you know being
a kid in the suburbs there wasn't a lot
of other kids whose parents would let
them hang out with me because my brother
was in jail at the time so again that
gave more fuel to the anger to wanna use
sports as my outlet to express myself
because you couldn't talk about it you
couldn't say how you're feeling this is
just how sports was and I think still is
the environment in at least in the
Midwest where I grew up you weren't
allowed to express these things as a guy
as a male straight jock right it wasn't
acceptable and that fueled a lot of my
my passion to prove people wrong early
on to achieve to show that I was
successful or powerful or good or
whatever maybe and that was where the
drive came from being wanting to be a
great athlete you know I wanted to be a
professional athlete I wanted to be an
all-american and I achieved all those
things the challenge is when the
identity is stripped as you know a lot
of athletes who that go broke after a
couple years of being retired and the
identity is stripped from from us so
difficult it's the most challenging
thing to overcome you may not think so
because these are all star athletes who
had it all you know they're talented
they're successful they made money but
when an identity is stripped from anyone
I don't care if they've had it all or
not when we lose our identity and we
have nothing else to fall back on no
other skills and we're celebrating
acknowledged for our identity it's
really hard to say well Who am I what's
the point of being here there may be a
lot of folks out there who are veterans
coming home who have similar ass but
their identity is stripped when we lose
a job you're stripped when you get a
divorce your identity is stripped you
were once this power couple or this
married couple that always went to the
same places together and now your
friends are divided you know so then
Louis house here in the Richardson show
that's when you reach for those three
simple things I mean I think you got to
figure out your own reason why you're
here you know I got think you'll figure
out what's my purpose for being here you
know we may not and again
kind of going off here I'm on this but
we may not know why we're here right and
we talk about life issues here not sure
we may not know why we're here I think
we're always discovering look what is
the purpose of this why am I here what's
the what's the reason for my life what's
the meaning am I supposed to be on this
path am I supposed to be in this
relationship am I supposed to be playing
this position or whatever is happening
and I think that's our what I have found
is that living in gratitude helps and
suffering helps end the pain that we
feel inside because again if we see
perspective of walk down the street you
see homeless people out there man I've
got a pretty good life when we see
perspective in our experience then we
can start taking ownership for what we
do have an appreciation as opposed to I
wish I don't know the tea was hotter
today or something you know the little
things that we complain about and become
irrelevant
so appreciation gratitude is a must for
me because it keeps me very grounded it
keeps me grounded of looking how good I
do have it even if I feel like well I
lost my sport and I lost my dream and I
lost all my money and I this happened to
me when I was a kid and you know
whatever I've gone through this
challenging breakup but look at all the
good we do have and I think when we
focus on the good more good comes to us
and then you know these are life issues
normally obviously we're we're into the
escapism stuff here you know yes talking
about the Niro movies today and what
happened on Franta sea football or you
know your draft right that sort of stuff
so it's fine that we that we can get
real throw up but you you sometimes had
some some athletes on your pod right
mm-hmm
what are you what have you seen from
some of these athletes that you've had
that that's kind of that you've gleaned
about what makes them successful the
greatest athletes that you know I've had
the fortunate any of you Ray Lewis and
Maria Sharapova and Novak Djokovic and a
lot of other great athletes but you know
when I interviewed ray and I'm not sure
if you've interviewed him oh my god what
a presence right what a power what uh
and here's what they all have in common
they all have a lot of things in common
but the unwavering belief in themselves
is undeniable of how powerful their
sense of confidence and belief I
remember interviewing ray and I was like
what was your ritual before every game
I'm not sure if he'd told you this or he
talks about a public
he said I wouldn't even go out in the
city the night before you know we'd get
off the bus he roams the streets he does
and he talks to people it's quite do
that after games - well this is what he
said he said before the game he would go
into his room the night before whenever
his done roaming the streets he would go
in and essentially create a spiritual
experience visualizing what he was going
to do the pain he was going to inflict
on the competitors the next day and he
would get in a robe take a bath like
candles and have a spiritual experience
about the vision and the belief in
himself for tomorrow tomorrow's game and
I think that level of commitment and
vision and dedication to their craft is
what makes him so special you know you
saw Tom versa time the the dedication to
film at this age is even greater than
when he was in college probably he is so
committed to his craft it's hard to beat
someone who was willing to do whatever
it takes and not only willing to do
whatever it takes but then steps on the
field and says I have done absolutely
everything in my power to know every
person's name every first step every
insecurity they have and I know
everyone's weakness did ray tell you the
candles were my idea were they I like
that Sam I prepare for this no ray you
know that that's Ray's just he's a
unique guy he just did the wall he just
did the whole thing with with a with a
headset mic and he around he explored
the the Canton stage were you there I
was was it inspiring
it was indeed every time around that guy
just like gives me goosebumps yeah I
know I hear you and you're on Facebook
watches well you've got a summit of
greatness coming up in Columbus is your
favorite town I know it's look the Ohio
State is an incredible place I've I've
seen a video shoe I've never been inside
that what
I mean come on you serious Louis I
haven't been to the big house but I will
go there I don't come to the Shu no I
understand we'll go I understand how you
know positive and inspiring the world is
on occasion I might have a problem
walking into the horseshoe you know it's
funny huh I tell quick story about this
please I was at the game was it last
year
what were they playing last year at the
big house yes so the year before I was
at the game the one where of Michigan
won because there was a no house they
played a blatantly miscalled fourth down
measurement that game so you mean the
one that Ohio State won that's that one
yeah okay cool
so I'm sitting in the Michigan parent
section oh boy there was like a little
section with Michigan fans it's all the
parents right yeah and it was actually
Tom Brady's managers got me the tickets
okay right from from Tom so I got the
Michigan ticket section damn and I
couldn't wear Ohio State because I
didn't want to be that guy in the middle
of all these parents who are like
rooting for their sons and but I was
sitting there just like so happy every
time something happened good but I
couldn't scream because I wanted to be
respectful of Michigan fans because I
care about you guys as well just letting
you know Louis you are an empathetic and
division rush the field it was a the end
ever what did was amazing and you and
you and you held up the referees is off
the field he gave him the Rudy treatment
long off so it again that's a that's a
three day event if we featuring
workshops in Columbus and Columbus on
October 4th through October 6th yeah get
your pod school of greatness yeah and
then inspiring life with you Louis house
on Facebook watch every single Monday at
noon Eastern that's it thanks for coming
on the show you got it come back any
time
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience